[Music]
you can have a regular normal body guy
with his shirt off trying to inspire
people you can add me a guy with no legs
and one arm
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Nick sentenced ah so I have
Han heart syndrome and Han heart
syndrome is a rare genetic disorder
which either leaves the baby with
undeveloped limbs or undeveloped organs
when my case it was just my limbs that
were you know affected middle school was
like my rock bottom was always asking
you know why was I born like this had
suicidal thoughts wrestling started me
on you know the answer to why I had to
have standing ovations when I lost and I
just didn't understand because I'm a
very competitive person I'm like you're
not supposed to like cheer on someone
that loses after the matches I'd have
parents come to me be like hey like my
kid never did a sport and he saw you
today and now he signed up for all these
sports you know because he sees that if
you're doing it like there's no excuse
for him not to it was like that's why
I'm here and I wanted to break into the
fitness industry because I was inspired
by these Fitness guys that you know sit
around with their six-pack makes their
nice car but getting into it it's much
more than that
it's how you can move people and show
them that like living a healthy
lifestyle is not as hard as you think it
is especially if I can do
my life revolves around you know eating
and training and posting I look at being
fit I look at motivating inspiring as if
duty I got a message from a UK mom she
had twins and one of the twins legs had
to be amputated
she said that they watched the videos
together and he goes like me Mom he's
like me mom I didn't have that as a kid
I didn't have someone to look up to that
kid can you know oh I don't know how to
do this let me look at next page that
that's why I do
[Music]
[Applause]